content strategy so the content
strategies how do we pick great topics
and how do we get people to consistently
follow through on watching our videos so
first thing to look at is link so how
long should a video be people always ask
me how long should a video be ideally
it's 10 minutes plus and we've been
talking about this push the at least 10
minutes but there is no upper limit if
you can go for three hours go for three
hours we're seeing the biggest growth in
the one to three hour category not live
streams so we can talk about that if you
guys want but actual recorded videos
that you upload that are one to three
hours is the biggest growth segment
right now in thought leadership on
YouTube one to three hours are pretty op
says Drew longer is better longer is
definitely better you can make a better
video of his videos five and you can go
45 talk about the same thing you will do
better the first minute really matters
and we'll talk about that but overall
longer is better so if I pull up Anita's
Channel
uh these are decent videos these are
these are long but her new ones are long
right 28 minutes 49 minutes 28 minutes
her most recent three that I pulled up
last night some of her older ones I
think these were just clips from her
show a minute a minute a minute a minute
these are all basically one minute clips
from the show uh until you get to here
which are longer sessions again these
one minute Clips are basically dead if
you if you're gonna do YouTube shorts
cool that can work those are vertical
videos and they have to be under one
minute
um but
these videos are are basically dead one
minute videos don't go anywhere on
YouTube inside Bond leadership uh now
her old ones here she also has an
hour-long video and she's got a 40
minute video and this is this is
interesting so here she uh this was a
presentation she did to I don't know if
they were local women business owners or
entrepreneurs or what the what the theme
was but
um this was her presenting on a topic in
the beginning was even really long
delayed because nothing happened at the
start and it was a long introduction and
then she came on
um but long videos if you can go long
amazing in this style of doing
interviews with people uh this is how
Joe Rogan blew up is making three hour
episodes two and a half hour episodes
four hour episodes so if you can go
longer Anita with any of these people I
would I would go longer for sure and I
would look at doing more stuff like this
as well where you're presenting or
speaking or just direct the camera stuff
as well where you can go and kind of
Deep dive master class on something
because you have a good chance people
will people will watch if they're
learning people are watching if they're
learning I don't want to overwhelm and
stress everybody out
so if he's like hey make one hour video
seven days a week
like Evan I'm gonna rip off my hair it
would look like you if I do that
so you know we have that we have to
build a sustainable model in here 15
minutes are great uh but 10 minutes is
the minimum and and the the whole idea
of saying one to three hours is you
don't need to cut it off so some of
these it looks like her interviews
Anita's been really they're all about
the same 20 28 23 28 25 28 30. so these
interview shows are all kind of that
same length and maybe she's cut off
maybe Anita has restrictions she's using
the studio maybe she has to get an ad on
a certain time you know maybe there's
other reasons for it
she she says I was aiming for 28.30 so I
don't know where that number comes from
but if if you're having great guests on
having great conversations
the hardest part is getting people to
click and then watch the first minute
after that they'll continue to watch for
the most part uh and so if you're having
great conversations I would not end it
early
um
obviously pay attention to your your
your health and you know you're not
going too crazy and four hour interviews
are burning you out that's a real thing
but if you can't go along with anybody
do not be afraid to go long do not cut
it short just because you feel like it
has to be short longer videos are
popping off the next is the retention
curve so this is the the most important
part of the YouTube analytics to look at
and there's so many things you can get
lost in with YouTube analytics
um that I don't want you to worry about
and stress out about I love geeking out
about it I know Drew loves geeking out
about it
um but you don't have to stress out
about all the analytics the most
important one is this the audience
retention curve which shows you where
people are falling off
so the goal should be and this is a
really hard number to hit especially
consistently 70 at one minute so here on
this video at one minute was 73 audience
retention and this is what your audience
retention curve should look like this
basically means where are people falling
off when people are watching your video
you should you should look at this video
you should look at the stats for your
videos this really really really really
really really matters if you've been if
you've been
eaten something or or getting distracted
by something right now has been talking
or I see Edge on his bike
crushing it doing getting this work and
then this is important focus on this
look at the curve for your videos
because it shows you what your audience
is leaving you for so where are people
bouncing on your videos what did you say
what did you do where people are losing
interest in your videos this will help
you make better videos so it's not just
about what you think would look good
it's not just about what I think might
be good it's what people who are on
YouTube are actually saying about your
video without them watching without
their typing in the chat nobody's going
to come and type in the chat said hey
you know what at the 15 second mark it
got kind of boring so I left
nobody's giving you that direct feedback
but this Curve will give you that
feedback and show you where your videos
are falling apart okay so anytime where
it's like this flat line or increase
this is these are really good moments
people rewound that part to watch it
again
but in general you should ideally see
this slow curve where you're slowly
losing people over time that's okay but
for the most part we see big drops
especially at the beginning part of a
video and you know Anita can look at
hers and all of you can look at your own
as well if you see a big drop then
if you're at I've seen some channels
where it's like 15 at one minute so
you've lost 85 percent of the people in
the first minute of your video so this
is where short attention span really
matters if you're 85 after the first
minute you could have an hour-long video
that is basically a waste of time
because you've lost almost all of your
audience right at the beginning
so we've trained in the past about
powerful opinion thought leadership
templates and and we can revisit some of
that content as well let's not we're not
going to Deep dive on that and this one
just out of interest of time but paying
attention to your audience attention
curve and as you test different things
you need to hook people for that first
minute and then once they're in for a
minute they're most likely going to
stick and slowly watch the rest of it so
that really really matters you can look
at this this is free this is no added
product this is all built within YouTube
it shows you for every single video on
your channel you can look at it
uh and it's really good data to pay
attention to this is the most important
data to pay attention to because if
people are are watching your videos
YouTube will reward you more remember
YouTube's goal keep you on YouTube all
day long
right so if you're helping keep them on
YouTube YouTube will reward you this was
an example of a bad video
um so here she was doing a dancing she
was doing a dancing routine she called
it let's dance uh but she didn't start
dancing until here
so you know one minute it was 22
retention that's really bad and people
are like fast forwarding fast forward
like where's the dance it's calling a
dance I want to see you dance so the
beginning she's not even on you know at
the beginning of the video it's just her
apartment
now this is probably this is a really
bad example it's probably not what most
of you are doing
um but it's really worth paying
attention to so if you see a curve like
this like wow I lost 70 you know five
per plus percent of my audience in the
first minute but then I did something
good here and then I did something good
here
you know what to improve and you know
what to fix and this is on a video by
video basis not on the whole channel
it's video by video you can see so if
you want to test a different intro so
you know what this time I'm going to
stand up or this time I'm gonna I'm
gonna dance or this time I'm gonna
Channel Zane the man and have more
confidence and energy coming through or
this time I'm going to leave with a
question or this time I'm going to start
with a powerful opinion you know all of
those things are great experiments and
the data will then show you what people
like and don't like so it says matching
of what you want to do with what works I
don't want to give you something that
feels super uncomfortable that is
against your brain or is not
um in line with your values cool don't
do that
but inside of the things that you do
want to do what actually works and this
is the data that we'll show you
so you should be looking at all your
videos and look at the retention curve
and see where you're at
how do I say one story stick with it to
have the call to action what I want
people to gain from it because I can
tell stories but I haven't quite
figured out how to make it work for the
other person so the best stories that
you say from stage are the ones where
you are helping people first right like
the best stories that I've told are
because I help people one-on-one first
because when you're speaking live on
stage to a group of people you don't get
a lot of fantastic feedback like you can
kind of look at their faces and see
what's going on but they have a lot of
thoughts and and and yeah butts and
what-ifs in their head but they're not
expressing them but when you sit down
with somebody one-on-one
you get the feedback
you get to see you get to see what
they're thinking you get to hear the
real thoughts going on in their head
and so my best stories have come the
stories that I tell on stage is stories
I just told in Vegas I've told countless
times to people one-on-one and I know
how to tell the story so that it moves
them to a result
you can have a million different stories
and it's awesome that you're a
Storyteller Stories the the point is to
get people to move towards some kind of
action so the key is figuring out which
story to tell in which context so if I'm
If You're Gonna Go on stage and speak
what's the end goal that you want to
have happen
and then what's the right Story to Tell
in this situation
does that make sense
I'm figuring it out
I would practice telling more stories to
more individual people
and asked them what they thought
gotcha and and especially the resistance
like where does it not make sense
okay I'll tell you a quick story
okay
I had eye surgery
um
the end of last month
and when I went to my doctor's office he
said I could go back to work I work in
the ER and I decided I need a doctor's
note
not to work till July so that I can sit
with what I really want to do with this
in this space
and so
the story for me is I have no income
so I have to figure
if I really want to be in this space or
not because just the way to help people
is to be able to be consistent and to
have a way to pay my bills otherwise I'm
not going to be in this space I'll go
back because every time I'm in the year
I can't I can't fit into this space it's
a different Zone
so the story for me is to tell people
that are 60 year olds in healthcare that
they need to live their best life
even though they've lived a best a
better life in something they know it's
okay to Pivot
because if you don't
what are you going to do at the end of
life
and so I mean that that's I mean that's
why I did it that's the story I told
myself
and so I'm just trying to figure
how to take life situations and make it
stories to help people
make decisions and I made that decision
to say I've burned that bridge is it a
permanent bridge I think it is
but I have to make it work that's why I
came on the call
no I love it and
your your journey
becomes the story so a couple things in
there right like you haven't done the
thing yet right you haven't built the
successful career outside of healthcare
yet no so we can't say here's what I've
done you know look at what I've done
but
the story is that you have the courage
to try
and the willingness to try
and you're going to make mistakes and
you're going to have self-doubt and
you're going to not be sure if it's
working out or not
and the willingness to try is the
inspiration
so
if if we're telling a story
if my main call Action was I want people
to be willing to try like if that's the
message be willing to try
right you could have tons of stories but
my takeaway from this one is hey be
willing to try
so when our people are around you or
they hear your speech or they watch your
video I need to feel like I I should go
off I've got an idea I need to be
willing to try if Dr O's going to go off
and do it and and I need to be willing
to try as well
so the message is be willing to try then
you can tell a story around it gotcha
let me tell you guys I I'm I'm here
trying to I'm trying to do it too like I
haven't started living my life yet I'm
trying I don't know all the steps I'm
trying to figure it out I know that I
don't want to see any ER anymore
because it makes me feel X like whatever
it actually makes you feel
and I know I want to be in a different
spot and I'm tired of of people telling
me that I'm too old
and I'm tired of telling myself that I'm
told and that I can't change
and then whatever whatever like the
actual thoughts are in your head that
when you wake up because you don't wake
up every day and like I'm gonna go crush
this goal it's like what what are the
actual thoughts in your head because
that's what brings us in and makes it
personal okay
and then you share and I'm I still get
up every day because I'm willing to try
and I want to make this happen
so that when I walk away I've been
inspired by the story
but my takeaway is be willing to try
gotcha thank you very much now when
you're talking to somebody one-on-one
then you can ask for feedbacks okay so
what are you gonna do now
and you see what this are they actually
off ready to try something or are they
still dealing with their own doubts and
insecurities
because when you're speaking on stage
again you're speaking to a a group of
people you don't get that feedback
but if you can if you can structure you
have so many stories to tell cool they
don't all have to fit into one video or
one speech
one main message per video per speech
that when I walk away with if you think
like the event I just came back from in
Vegas
it's like it was three days four days I
don't remember so many speakers
everybody gets up there's another speech
another speech that's like it's speech
overload like you guys have all been to
events and it's just crazy speech
overload so to to
hope that somebody remembers everything
that you're going to say is impossible
so it's like what's the one thing that
I'm going to get from your message
that I can take away that you are you
are the most valuable person for me from
that event
and it's such that you having that
intention as opposed to just standing up
saying I've got a bunch of stories to
tell
gotcha good luck all right milco in the
house I saw him bouncing what do we got
Milko my question it's not very well
formed uh but
for me because from what I know a good
storytelling you need to show emotions
it's kind of like last time we kind of
covered this and you showed us how you
actually took your 700 videos or what
was them or something like that to find
your uh self and be yourself on camera
so for me because I usually I'm not used
to sharing my emotions in any way so I
usually uh I'm usually quite intense
when I coach people but I don't share my
emotions and I know that for example for
storytelling when you show your emotions
when you share them uh it's much better
and people can relate to you more so I'm
trying to
find this voice but I can't really make
the difference because sometimes I I
feel like I'm really putting it there
and I'm kind of showing my emotions and
stuff like that and then it turns out
that the video that it's not uh or
someone else is telling me that it's not
really sounds a bit a bit uh not genuine
and so on so so kind of
I'm not sure where I'm going with this
but you know
so listen I mean if you if you go back
and watch our session from a couple
weeks ago is you know I I
self-criticized my videos or critique
them going back and and uh when I got
the feedback to have more emotion you
see my very my very beginning videos
that the content was still almost to
what I talked about now
the delivery was way off it's like okay
guys so I got a question from my reader
and you know it's like it's just super
boring watching it back and then when I
got the feedback to try to do more
emotion it felt forced right like as I
was critiquing my videos like look at
that video like I'm trying there is more
energy but it's not real Evan energy
it's a forced energy but it's it's
better than what it was but it's not
where it needs to be and it's still
pushing through that discomfort to uh
practice and work on it because it was
80 there some of the things are right
but I had to keep
I had to keep trying it on to like make
make it fit for me one of the best
things that helped me this advice I told
Alex too who's in the house so we could
talk about him
um when Alex first started doing stories
at TDS uh China van salsa he was he was
doing stories at the front of the class
he's doing stories on videos it all
sucked I mean like what we all suck at
the beginning right and Alex and Alex
and add to the chat if he wants kind of
sharing stuff but
um it was really bad and and the points
were still good but the delivery was
just really really bad
um and so the exercise I gave him was
whenever you feel the emotion film
so whenever you feel like that
Breakthrough video for me I figure what
number was like 670 something
um
was because I came back from that event
I was trying to help entrepreneur I was
so frustrated and so I I just filmed I
had no idea what I was gonna say and I
just filmed and the energy was on point
the content wasn't as good but the
energy was so much better
and it's the energy that's actually
going to carry the day and so whenever
you feel the emotion if if you just come
out of movement makers and you feel
grateful or you just come out of a
coaching call and you feel frustrated or
whatever has happened like you feel
emotions throughout your day
they just may not be there when you're
about to press record on the camera
so the trick is have your phone with you
which we probably all do and and when
you feel that emotion you film
and it does two things
one
it it gets you
the practice of speaking from your heart
because we're speaking from our head
with most of our videos so it gets you
the practice of speaking with your heart
and letting that Express because you
feel what it feels like but you you
haven't practiced vocalizing what it
feels like and so it gets you that
practice the second thing is when you go
to try to tell that story again if
you're gonna then tell that story on
stage you can tell that story in a
future video you can go back and watch
how you delivered it when you were
actually in that state and then you can
think back to yeah that's how I felt
because it's hard to manufacture that
sometimes when you're just sitting at
home on your ball kind of bouncing
around figuring out you know talking
about food choices right
um so that's the best activity that I
would recommend it's like try to catch
it during the week and then film even if
you don't post it just try to catch an
emotion any a positive or negative
emotion
and film it and don't stress if it sucks
and don't stress if it's not well
thought out or
um you don't really know what you're
saying as you go but just practice that
because the more you practice that the
better you'll get at it and again you
can go watch it back and say yeah that's
what it feels like to have that that
thought again so you could get out of
your head and into your heart
thank you so very helpful yeah I
remember one time where like when I was
really grinding on Alex to do this we're
at a uh we're at a dance event so we we
hosted these dance parties once a week
or so and um he was uh
uh he I forget he had some kind of
emotion right he was upset or he was
happy I don't remember what it was like
dude go film like now yeah go go film
now and and then he he filmed yeah it's
like that's what you need to train
yourself to do you're feeling emotional
film film even if just for yourself to
get the repetition down
this is an extra special topic
self-publishing versus getting an agent
publisher I've got four books two of
them these two were self-published and
that's just through Amazon this one was
with your one word was my first book my
major book that was with penguin random
house that was with a six-figure advance
uh and the typical publishing deal and
then built the serve was it's almost a
hybrid so we did build the serve with
Mel Robbins label uh who she published
the five second rule with and it's it's
a hybrid in that it's it was no Advance
on this one but much bigger royalties
so typically with a publisher you get
you might get an event you might not
depends on how big your your list is and
your audience is
but you get paid very little for every
book that's sold here's I'm betting more
on myself and so less well zero on the
advance compared to six figures on this
one and I get paid more for every book
that I sell so let's talk about how to
pick self-publishing versus publishing
to help you make the best decision it
starts off with what are your goals okay
so anytime somebody's asking me there's
no one size fits all like what do you
want to accomplish so I'm going to start
by making the case for self-publishing
here's why you want to self-publish one
you have a bucket list to have a book
some people just want to have a book
it's on their bucket list or they
promise their mom they write a book or
they was in their High School yearbook
that they're going to have a book like
if you just want a book because it means
something to you because you want to
have something on the shelf or because
it's on your bucket list then the
easiest thing to do is just self-publish
it you don't need to go through the
hassle and headache and pain of trying
to go get a publisher just make it
yourself and poof you have your book
if you want to make money from the
actual book then you want to sell
publish because you keep just so much
more of the revenue from each book
compared to going with a major publisher
where you make basically nothing right
there's a small royalty on every single
book sold but if the goal is to make
money from the book itself
you're going to self-publish you keep
just a much much much larger percentage
if you have other goals which we'll talk
about on the publishing side there's
reasons for that but making money from
the actual book or self-publishing
if you want to use it as a funnel for
lead gen
so if you want to create a book it's
fast to set up you then use that to then
get into your funnel to then get into
your coaching to get into your products
to then get into whatever you ultimately
have to sell you have a funnel attached
to it
you'll get a much lower cost with your
own book self-published and you will
going with the publisher so you get your
book for cheaper so it's easier to send
out to people it costs you less to start
building your funnel at that front end
compared to if you get a book with a
publisher
so this is if you've got your sequence
worked out and you know you know your
entry-level product and then your next
level product and then your coaching and
in your Mastermind or whatever that
looks like for you at least having
thoughts of a roadmap a book can be a
great first step in and self-publish
gets you at a great price you get it out
quickly
one of the uh biggest Pains of
publishing is it takes like a year to
get the book out
it's a giant pain
it's other people critiquing you it's
it's slow as anything it takes you a
while to write it and anybody who's gone
through the writing process you know how
long it can take to write and rewrite
and research and edit and all that stuff
but then when you're when it's finally
done it's like okay I'm ready here we go
and then it's another year before the
book actually comes out just because of
how long Publishers take to go through
their machine so if you want to get
something out you know if it's if it's
May right now and you want something out
this year it's not going to happen with
a publisher
so now we're already talking next year
if you want about this here you're
self-publishing you get it out super
fast
you get to be in complete control
so another frustration with any bit of
creative work is the critique to say no
don't don't do that don't put in that
chapter don't call it this I don't like
the name of your book that's not going
to sell very well and it's it's crazy
how little research a lot of the the
organizations do a lot of the publishing
companies do
um when I was picking my cover or when I
was picking the title it's all based off
of their feel there's no Market data
there's no testing with people it's
really just whoever you're dealing with
do they like the concept or not and sure
they have some industry experience so
it's not like a total newbie opinion but
uh it's not it's never based off of what
the audience is actually asking for
needs and they have they have very
little knowledge about the audience that
you're going after so if you want to be
in complete control if you don't want to
have uh somebody telling you what colors
to use what font to use what what layout
to use what Graphics to use what to call
it any of that stuff then
self-publishing is the way to go
you own the rights which is a huge deal
so you can do whatever you want with it
now I've you can negotiate some rights
into your deals if you're working with
the publisher so for example I own the
YouTube rights the social media rights
for my books so I could just release the
whole book on YouTube or on Instagram or
on clubhouse if I wanted to
because I own the rights
because they don't really Publishers
haven't really caught up to that yet
we're not thinking what you're going to
put a book on YouTube
okay sure whatever here you go right
um so you get to own the rights and do
whatever you want with it in the future
so this is the case for self-publishing
these are the reasons why you want to
sell publish okay publisher why to go
with the publisher what is the reason so
one bestseller list if that means
something to you this is something
that's never meant much to me because
you can game the system so easily to get
on a bestseller list people
literally just buy their way on to
bestseller lists and the way that they
do it which nobody talks about but
movement makers Insider knowledge let's
let's share what happens like how does
somebody get number one status what they
do is they drop the price for one day or
on Amazon it's it's by uh hour they drop
the price of the ebook version to one
cent
so for one hour for one day they dropped
the price to one cent They then send
tons of people you can hire services to
do this whether it's your own email list
but they have a whole bunch of people
with email lists that then just say go
buy this book for one cent
ebook and then it blows up off the
charts boom you're a bestseller and then
the next hour drops back down and and
your you know time when the sun is gone
but you can say I'm a bestseller so if
if you if you want that just because it
adds some credibility or means something
to you then it's it's a lot easier to do
it with a publisher than
um than on your own
uh Prestige and branding there is still
some cachet to having a published book
versus something that you self-published
it's dramatically dropping this is one
of the biggest fights that I got into
with my agents like you need a book
every need to book ever need a book why
do we need a book you need a book to get
on stage you need a book to to get
Partnerships you need a book to open
doors like Steve I can open doors with
my YouTube channel
I don't I don't need a book anymore it's
not that books can't help you do that
but there's lots of ways to do that if
you had a big YouTube audience you can
open doors if you had a big Clubhouse
audience there's people who are building
up on clubhouse right now who six months
you've never heard of and they're
getting
Grant Cardone into their rooms and
they're getting Jay Shetty into their
rooms and they're getting they become
they're they're they've opened the doors
they're now somebody just because of the
three months of investment they made
onto Clubhouse so Prestige and branding
can be there it's just dramatically
dropping it used to be the only way or
one of the only ways now there's tons of
ways to be able to build your brain but
if that again means something to you
then publish book still has a little bit
of cachet
editing support
was super helpful of all the things that
a publisher
what you think a publisher helps with
most of them most of the things they
don't but editing was actually really
helpful
so on the editing side I was making
typos I can't believe how many typos I
made
I write it out and I'm I feel like I'm a
pretty good writer you know and not
somebody who failed English class I'm a
pretty good writer and then I would read
the whole thing
and and catch some typos but then I give
to them like oh wow you made so many
times wow I can't believe how many typos
I made it's crazy I even gave it to my
friends and family to go through and
read give it to 30 people each time to
go through and read and they caught some
typos but then still the editors caught
typos
so and there's still one typo in your
one word that made it through that
everybody missed
uh so it's a little sad the editing
support is very real and I think if you
if you can't afford it then you hire net
if you're gonna sell publish you hire an
editor or even just try to find who is
your uh do you have a friend who's just
really really detail-oriented and great
at editing who can help you you know
lend lend an extra pair of eyes to it
um next formatting support
formatting is formatting especially for
ebooks really sucks you know if you're
if you're creating your book and you you
make it in a Word document and then you
try to translate that to an Amazon
format especially with ebooks where
there's no where it's like infinite
scroll it's such a giant pain now I I
gave it to somebody on my team for the
self-published stuff I said Ray just
figure it out
because it was driving me nuts and Ray
loves new challenges but that took a
couple weeks of his of his life just
trying to figure out how to format the
book to be on Amazon especially for the
ebook and when you go with the publisher
they just take care of all of that stuff
easily for you be in the bookstores
again it's less and less and less
important most bookstores are either
closing down or are supplementing you
walk into a bookstore and a lot of them
are half furniture stores or lifestyle
stores and selling vases and flowers and
a bunch of other stuff so it's not as
important but if you want to get into a
bookstore the Publishers have the
relationships it's not impossible as a
self-published book but it's almost
impossible as a self-published book to
get into bookstores so again that means
something to you if you want to
roll into your Barnes and Nobles with
your family and take a picture you know
view with the book here on the shelves
uh then you have to go with the
publisher
today we are talking about documenting
versus creating I'm going to talk about
where this docking versus create comes
from from garyvee my take on it how you
can get started so document versus
create let's talk about first where it
came from this was this is a garyvee
idea
he came up with it just on a in a random
moment in an interview that then became
something much bigger where what he's
trying to do and I agree with this part
is to get people to make
so many of you have a great message a
great Mission something deep inside you
a story to share and and we're just not
making enough we're just not creating
enough and so where he started to fall
in with document versus create was don't
stress out about having the perfect
version of things don't stress us about
uh spending 100 hours on one video
you could document your journey and
release that as content so this is
actually what started to help Gary's
Channel blow up was when he shifted from
just having a Regular Show so his
YouTube channel used to be his keynote
speeches then he created the askgaryvee
show which was people asking him
questions and that was I don't know
maybe once a week and then it evolved to
having his camera guy drock come follow
him around
and he was just living his day and then
out of each day filmed you know in 8 12
15 minute video
and so what he's saying is hey instead
of worrying about creating creating
creating all the time these Fancy videos
just document your life document your
journey and that can be content
I am not completely aligned with it as a
strategy for you guys I'm going to tell
you why I'm going to tell you the pros
and cons and and hopefully guide your
content strategy so you can get that
message inside you out there to the
world so here's why I'm not a giant fan
of it for you
uh one requires a lot more editing so if
you are if you're garyvee you can afford
to hire somebody to follow you around
and film content for you that's great
I mean that's amazing it's probably not
you know the people here right but how
amazing would that be if somebody's
following you around and they're going
to do the filming and the editing and
put it all together and take your you
know 10 hour day and turn it into an
eight minute video right
or 10 minute video uh
it's a lot harder when it's on your own
and requires a lot more editing so if
you think about you're filming your
progress you're filming your daily
routine you're filming your your process
throughout the day everything you're
learning
that's a lot more cuts a lot more
editing and it often just doesn't train
the skill that you want to be great at
your goal should be to be great in front
of the camera not to be great as an
editor now if anybody here your ambition
is to be a great editor awesome that can
work but for most of you your goal
shouldn't be to spend five hours inside
the editing Bay cutting Clips together
so it's a lot harder when you're doing
Clips throughout the day or Clips
throughout multiple days to then splice
them together it's a lot more editing
required versus some of the other
content models I have talked about and
we'll talk about today the second thing
is it's a lot harder to keep track of
the story so if you're if you're filming
throughout the day or if you're filming
a challenge throughout multiple days it
can be hard to remember where you left
off
where you started what the last thing
you said on camera was what you said
yesterday because you need to tie a
consistent story together the arc if you
want people to continue to follow along
with what you're doing and then lastly
is the videos don't often perform as
well
those kind of videos rarely perform as
well as uh some of the other content
formats we've talked about interviews
direct the camera uh mentorship q a
those kinds of content often perform
better than this kind of content unless
it's super well edited so a lot of This
falls down to the editing and the
ability to to bring the stories together
into an arc and that's that's a lot of
work and maybe it's what you want to do
but probably not for you guys so
in the past and I love Gary I Had Gary
on the channel a month ago talking about
uh book launches and in our last session
if you guys go back on our session two
weeks ago we talked about how to use
Instagram live to be able to create
content to get your message out there I
think all of these options are much
easier than documenting or creating I
think this is this is the fastest and
easiest way for you to start creating
content and get your message out there
because a 25 minute session actually is
only 25 minutes where to document your
day and everything you're doing and then
edit that all together is going to take
you a lot more than 25 minutes right
you're looking now at hours so coaching
mentoring interviews q a uh or using
Instagram lives to do Biz Dev or reward
the people on your team uh or people who
are or your customer base
Pablo saying but he said that we don't
need to make it pretty uh yes so here's
the thing try it right it's it's it's
really really really hard to get that
beta to do well
if you are not editing
a a journey kind of video
right so if you're gonna document your
journey
you could make them as many thought
leadership videos right if you took the
thought leadership template
and be able to serve and you lead
everybody with a powerful opinion and
what you're gonna do
as soon as you start cutting it up over
multiple days or even throughout the day
it requires you to now edit those videos
together and requires you to remember
what you filmed the last time right when
I make a thought leadership video now
when I'm doing a coaching I'm going to
do coaching sessions all day long today
right interviews and podcasts once I'm
done one I'm not thinking about the one
I just did right I'm moving on to the
next one but when you're doing this kind
of Storytelling when you're documenting
a journey you have to remember the last
thing that you said because if you don't
create a story arc for the people
watching there's they're not likely
going to watch the next thing like it's
harder for them to keep on top your your
hardcore fans and friends and family
will watch it but but my goal for you is
to reach a brand new audience and it's
just a lot harder it's not that it's not
possible and if you enjoy this style go
all in and do it it's just a lot harder
on the editing a lot harder on the
storytelling to create the arc and a lot
a lot harder to get the views on the
videos I love Gary and I love the intent
behind a message which is get content
out there
I just think for you the document
version is not your best path in just
keep in mind like if this doesn't work
for you if that if this format feels
like it's a lot of work compared to the
other content Styles it is that's okay
right and and pick there's no one right
strategy it's figuring out the one
that's right for you
so document versus create how to get
started here's what I would say
this is James altitude if you guys know
James or not he's an awesome author
entrepreneur
um I've had him on my show he was on I
was on his show and one of the things
that he said that really struck with me
was what am I embarrassed to be
struggling with and what am I doing
about it so if you're going to be doing
videos especially documenting videos you
need to have a theme
because just follow me around in my life
uh is not great thought leadership
content if you're really entertaining
you could go be a vlogger which which
could be great and lots of YouTubers
have made a ton of money a lot of reach
a lot of impact making vlogging videos
but it's not thought leadership content
it's not really spreading your message
right it's entertaining follow me around
look at my lifestyle right for you guys
if you want to teach people you're
remember you're a weird Duck Right you
think differently than most people think
your job is to make people think the way
you think if you want to teach people
there has to be some kind of theme to
kick this whole thing off and a great
way to do it is what are you currently
embarrassed to be struggling with
that someone like you shouldn't be
struggling with because you have to you
have to let me in and know that you're a
human because people want to learn not
from the perfect people because it feels
unattainable
they feel too perfect it's like well you
don't understand me
and so listen all of us have
insecurities I have insecurities you
have insecurities let me in let me know
what you're struggling with let me know
what you're embarrassed by let me know
what you haven't told other people yet
and then make that public and that and
that takes courage to do it but but
being a leader takes courage being a
thought leader takes courage getting
your message out there takes courage and
as long as you are silent on this thing
that you're embarrassed by it
perpetuates a Silence by you coming out
and saying I'm going to try to tackle
this and change this then it creates
permission for other people to change
and to not feel so
um isolated and alone right in your
courage and coming forward you allow
other people to feel like they belong a
little bit more as well so this is the
theme that I would start thinking about
like what are you embarrassed to be
struggling with and what are you going
to be doing about it and this could be
again if you don't want to do the
document version this is a great single
video this is a great interview this
this kind of thinking if you can think
about right now something that you're
embarrassed to be struggling with that's
a great piece of content for your social
your advantage is your humanness why
people will go with you is because they
can relate to you how do you get them to
relate to you when people say be
authentic be authentic what does that
mean this is what it means
it's it's being vulnerable sharing the
thing that you're afraid to share
take me inside
the fear take me inside I want to see
you saying I'm afraid to go live and
whatever the voice is in your head I I
don't like the sound of my voice I don't
like how I look on camera I don't think
anybody's going to watch I think people
are going to watch right whatever the
voice is inside your head
that other people will be able to
connect to right it's like these are the
real thoughts in my head that are
holding me back I'm embarrassed to be
struggling with this right now
and here's what I'm going to do about it
so you take people on that Journey right
that's a great start
so today's topic
how to reach your target audience I
think that's a great one I'm gonna go
over some of the concepts in build to
serve but also elaborate and go a little
deeper on it because I think this is
super important as we're planning for
2021 you guys have a message you got a
purpose you know that your message can
impact people uh a lot of us aren't
doing the work yet this is a good time
to start planning your content so in
build to serve
I lay out three different paths to how
to reach your audience one is the
fastest way one is the medium way and
one is the longest way and so fast fast
to Freedom Alliance Partnerships and
becoming a thought leader fast faster
freedom is the fastest way alliances is
kind of the medium term and thought
leader is the one that takes the most
time and yields the biggest results so I
want you to play with the three of them
so that you get some traction happening
into your business fast to Freedom so
page 194 in uh build the serve I think
you guys all have your copy if you're in
this group welcome welcome
this is really important so you know
we're talking about social media we're
using all these different accounts to
help build our brand but it can feel
overwhelming it can feel like there's so
many accounts where do I focus where do
I spend my time uh you're also trying to
run a business that's not your goal to
be a full-time you know influencer so
how do you do it so Step One is the fast
pass to freedom and what that means is
one you create all of the accounts on
social media I don't want you posting
everywhere and worrying about being a
thought leader everywhere because that
can get overwhelming but I want you to
own the name so that nobody else can
take it
I want you to have your picture up there
and ideally the same one across a
different platform so people can
instantly recognize you and I want you
to have what I call the amazing 10-pack
of content
uh the amazing 10-pack of content is in
the book it's here you're who your why
your how your recipe breakdown this is
how did you do how did you get out of
the hole that you were in that's
something that's teachable so I want
three posts on that I want to see the
results two examples of the results and
then give me hope make me feel like I
can get out of this as well 10 pieces of
well craft content
and then that's it
no more posting content the fast pass to
Freedom
is just getting your your names
registered so nobody else can do it you
get your picture your bio and your 10
pieces of content
and then we start outreaching
if you're just in the content creation
game without doing the Outreach it takes
longer to start building the momentum
totally possible totally doable but if
you're not being consistent and you're
not getting the results and you feel
like giving up
we need to start doing more Outreach to
get more immediate traction and momentum
so I put Zane domain here let me show
you Zane's account and we can give him a
little bit of feedback just starting
here so just owning a different account
so this is Zayn's Instagram
okay
um one I would zoom in on the face a lot
more I want a headshot Zan uh because
again looking at it on mobile it's going
to be hard to see when it's super far
out
uh the it's cut out super weird
so I would fix that uh because you're
dark and your suit is dark I wouldn't
have a black background I'd make it
something a lot brighter just like
you've got here you got the yellow and
the green and the blues and the Reds and
all this stuff so I would I would make
that brighter
so we have our picture right so we have
our Instagram account I'm not even
worried about all of this stuff yet
about posting the content right I'll
look at that IG live so cute we love
these two
there's Susie Susie in the house
um so we have our picture on the account
we have our bio I'm a certified
confidence coach author and entrepreneur
click the link below for coaching and
more info okay I would probably put in
here something about even DM me for
coaching
so I'm a certified confidence coach or I
help who I help entrepreneurs gain more
confidence uh so
something about being able to contact
you right the idea is the idea with the
fast passive freedom is
if your ideal client landed on your
profile page I want them to think about
hiring you
so of an ideal client someone who's
looking for confidence coaching landed
on Xander man's account I want them to
thank
I want to I want to reach out to Zane
so I would put something in here about
who you're targeting
so who do you help Zan if it's
entrepreneurs I help entrepreneurs gain
more confidence certify confidence coach
DM me if interested something like that
right here okay uh Zane's got a link
tree which is great so inside the link
tree you can have different uh different
links to different places
this links to his website this links to
his YouTube these are dead links then I
don't know if you knew that or not
so you click on Facebook it just goes to
facebook.com
[Laughter]
if you click on LinkedIn it just goes to
linkedin.com
and same thing with Twitter goes to
twitter.com
so we want to be fixing that and there
should be something about coaching here
right so it was you know it should be
DME for coaching but if you're going to
do it through a link tree there should
be something super obvious about how do
I get coaching
and this is a one-time thing that you
set up right it's it's high leverage
because we're assuming ideal clients are
coming to our page they're going to
click it we want to make it easy for
them so you're making a little more
difficult I mean you have the website
the website here you know is coming soon
the confidence formula I don't know what
this is this looks like a book join the
list so how do we get coaching you're a
coach
you're a certified confidence coach I
need coaching how do I get coaching
right now I'm like clicking through I
don't know how to get coaching right so
that you want to make that super super
obvious
uh so his name here is Zane the man
Smith so then I go to Twitter and there
is no xanderman Smith
so even if Zane has no interest in
Twitter yet and a lot of you I'm using
this as an example because I think a lot
of people are kind of in this boat
uh even if you have no interest in a
platform take the name so that nobody
else can take the name right so Zander
man Smith is what he is on Instagram I
want him to be Zander man Smith
everywhere
so when I go to Twitter xandoman Smith
this account doesn't exist
I want you to own this name I want you
to upload your picture
I want you to put in your bio
and I want you to post 10 pieces of
content and I want everybody to do this
for all the platforms even if you have
no intention of being there one you own
it so that nobody else can take it and
two if somebody does reach out to you
you are listen can respond
so in this phase for all the other
platforms so again Twitter Jose may not
care about but he wants to at least be
on there because if somebody does tag
him he can respond and he can say thank
you
you're just recognizing your Champions
and you're listening that's all because
just because Zane doesn't care about
Twitter maybe some other people do care
about Twitter maybe his clients are on
Twitter maybe somebody's saying Zan is
amazing I just saw him on movement
makers you want to be able to say thank
you because even if you don't have an
audience that person might have an
audience
so you get the name you put the picture
and then you're listening and you're not
going to get a thousand notifications
right I mean if you're getting a
thousand mentions every day great you
should be on that platform right like if
if one a month comes in yeah that's
great
but at least you're you know that that
one a month came in and you're paying
attention to them right so then you need
to get this account
um Tick Tock so Zayn owns Tick Tock heys
and good jobs and the man Smith he's got
the account on Tick Tock uh no bio yet
those in no bio so we gotta we gotta fix
our bio and make it the same on all the
platforms
make it the same bio uh you're using a
different picture for some reason on
this one right so Zayn the man here is
this kind of zoomed in one you know no
tie Zander man here is different so both
I would put both as the exact same and
again zoom in on the face this one's
easier to see you because of the lighter
background so you're going to stand out
a lot more here compared to this one but
either way I want you to zoom in on this
and and put a put a put a bio in so for
every platform maybe you're not using
Tech talk yet maybe you don't care about
tech talk and this again not just for
Zan everybody here
you still get you should get Tick Tock
slash your name
just to own it because that might become
the big thing that in five years
everybody's all over and and then
there's some other Zan the man who took
your name
right
uh and so that's a simple setup across
all the different accounts
um see a couple chats coming in here so
Susie was asking do you recommend a link
to your account I like linktree I'm a
fan of linktree it allows you to put
multiple links inside each
um so you just don't have one link I
would still add DME because the the
biggest thing that Zane wants to do is
get coaching clients that should be his
number one step coaching clients and so
I want DME for coaching and then I want
inside his link tree something about
coaching here's how to get coaching with
me even if it's just an email address
for coaching not a website that takes me
to a book that isn't out yet that I can
save 50 on
right and that's okay we love you same
way this is all love right I use
linktree
and if you look at mine as an example
I'm promoting my uh my YouTube channel
where we're doing a live show uh every
night and then my story the book
movement makers YouTube growth bootcamp
best life 30 right and a lot of the
posts that I'll put in I'll then say
check my check the link in the bio hey
if you're interested in Movie Makers
check the link in my bio so you could
also Zane could also be creating content
to say hey check the link in my bio for
coaching check the link in my bio for
whatever I wouldn't be trying to take
people away to a different platform so
when Xander was linking up
uh YouTube and then just random links to
Facebook Twitter and Linkedin right uh I
wouldn't try to send into another
platform I try to send them this is now
our funnel we want to try to get them to
move down the sequence with us to either
get their email address to get on a call
with them to get them to line as a
client right so what are the calls to
action here but the very basic one is
just coaching for Zen that's what he
wants to do it should be super easy for
me to find out how to get coached that's
just an example of of using zans right
uh in the book I go through how to make
these pieces of content you know who I
have recipe breakdown results examples
hope and then the key part here is
Outreach so you've got your picture
you've got your bio you've got the
account you've created your 10 pieces of
content and spent some good time
thinking about that and now it's
Outreach now we're not spending our time
making more content we're making we're
spending our time reaching out to people
we're spending our time commenting on
other posts so if I'm Zen instead of
making new content if he wants to help
coach entrepreneurs then I'm looking at
all the different entrepreneur accounts
so I'm looking at when Carmichael's
account I'm looking at garyvee's account
I'm looking at Grant cardone's account
I'm looking at Tom bilu's account I'm
looking all the people who are in my
space who you're kind of like
who that's your target audience and I
want to interact and answer questions
here's what's going to happen I post
something on my Instagram uh somebody
asked a question well we respond to
questions let's go someone else
um garyvee right he'll answer a couple
questions but most of the feed is not
getting a personal reply so Gary posts
something to his Instagram somebody
asked a question
Gary's not responding Zan jumps in and
gives a great response not just like hey
thank you for your question or or fist
bump or an emoji but really gives value
to help that person
what are they going to do who's a Zan
the man guy I love his answer they're
gonna go click on his account and what
are they going to see they're gonna see
a picture they're gonna see a great bio
they're going to see a link to be able
to get coaching I'm going to see his 10
pack of content
that's why we have to have all that in
place because if they come and they
don't see that then they're not going to
take the next step
so we're spending our time instead of
making new content we're spending our
time on Outreach to try to get people to
visit our profile page you don't have to
say visit my profile page please they're
just going to do it
because you gave them so much value and
them as well as other people who are
paying attention to the chat
so always try to pick the most recent
post if you go a week ago on garyvee's
Instagram as an example you're not gonna
there's gonna be a lot of comments but
most people aren't engaging in that
anymore
so they're going to be on the new staff
so always go to the newest one give your
two cents and start helping people in
the comments they're gonna check out
your page and if you've done this work
of a great picture great bio and 10 pack
of content then you start building leads
for your business at a much faster rate
than just trying to create organic
content that will get you reach
I'm gonna turn things over a little bit
to Josh here he's got some ideas to help
share with us today hello everyone so
great to see everybody can you take us
through an example because people are
asking about the YouTube igtv to YouTube
can you take us through an example of
flipping the video
so that if I'm recording in IG like can
you actually because this is being
recorded right so that people can then
like fast forward to this part too but
just don't know how to do this so
they're taking a vertical video from IG
and you want to put it to YouTube
how do we do it take like the IG live
that I did with Mark where we're above
each other
and then and then cut it so that we're
next to each other
a lot of people have to do that all
right so let's see if the one that's
what I'm going online I think that's the
easiest starting point for all of you if
you're doing coaching on igtv yeah yeah
there we go perfect okay all right so so
first thing you're gonna do
is you're going to duplicate this layer
so you're going to have two different
layers right
then what you're going to do is you're
going to disable the one layer
and then you're going to crop this so
you're going to go uh top
I can't see hold on I gotta move you
guys can't see what I'm doing here okay
I want to time this to see how long this
actually takes all right so you're gonna
pop this
oh snap look at that
so you're going to crop it
then you're gonna move it
if you want they found if you're
shooting in 4k you could actually make
it bigger but whatever you can just do
that
and then you're going to disable this
layer
actually you're not going to disable it
you're going to
um bring down the opacity the reason why
I do that because you want it to be kind
of even and then you're going to open
this layer
so now we're going to highlight mark
I'm actually going to bring it over to
where you are
I'm going to then scale it
to match it
nice
now I'm going to tell you the second why
it doesn't I'm just doing this in real
time but I actually already have all the
settings and I just copy and paste
so I just go to previous videos I copy
and paste on each layer and then it just
it does this automatically
but I don't have to I don't have to keep
doing that but I wanted to show you up
but yeah from scratch yeah this is great
people are saying awesome
uh Magic
and then yeah what's this software again
now they're paying attention this is
Final Cut this is Final Cut
Final Cut Pro but you can do this with
Premiere or anything
um then what I'm gonna do so let's let's
just make a
let's make a uh a brand for this right
but so even this guys like even this if
you make the pictures a little bit
bigger that already could just be a
YouTube video yeah yeah like how long
did that take I mean there's a couple of
settings you have to know but in in a
couple minutes you've already got igtv
to YouTube video post now you can add
some branding to it you can add some
logos you can add some captions if you
want you can do a lot of stuff make it
why you can add you can add a logo up
here you can put you know Evan
Carmichael Mark Drager so if you want to
show your guest one thing that we like
doing oh it's not even but uh I have it
automatically automatically from
previous ones I just copy and paste the
setting every time that I create a new
video I just copy and paste it then uh
often you can just do that by hitting uh
copy
and then if you do
it it'll just paint the setting right
onto that so that it'll automatically do
it so you don't have to keep moving it
around and whatnot and then you put your
title up because you can make that full
like you can make the white basically
disappear right like you can make me
take up half the screen you can make
Mark take up half the screen depending
on the let's see
so it just depends on the problem is
that the way it does is in square yeah
and this is 16 by nine okay so you
generally always have that's why you
feel so you see a lot of time in
broadcasting on ESPN you know they're
showing two different people because
most of the time they've been using Zoom
for years and it's always Square so they
put their little back but once again it
helps you put a little bit of branding
in the background you can make a 15 by
nine in in um in canva and just drop it
right underneath it just like I did this
this is underneath the layer so this
could be a picture this could be
whatever your branding it's all it's all
right here and then you can manipulate
this in any way you want I think we
should release a video like this where
Mark is much smaller than me I think
he'll I think he'll really freak out on
that one oh you mean like let's say
let's do that is the Market's gonna be
like there you go yeah nice yes it's
like I have my guest Mark Drager and
then do that for them for them for later
and then it's Evan oh man there you go
look at that but I mean it's so easy to
do I adding the lower thirds and the
graphics and all that stuff is you know
a bit of a challenge but hey look at
that we really should
we really should put that up as a video
um someone's asking again what's this
program this is amazing Final Cut okay
this is Final Cut Pro if you want to
watch the full version of this video as
well as train live with me twice a month
to help you build your movement and be
around some other amazing people just
like you check out my movement makers
program the link to join is right there
next to me can't wait to see you there
continue to believe and go join